Aircraft carriers are pretty impressive ships. When a plane is taking off,
it first needs to reach what we can call takeoff velocity.
If the plane is going any slower than this velocity,
it won't be able to generate enough lift to actually get off the ground.
Now an aircraft carrier's space is very limited.
So there's not a lot of time or distance to reach this velocity.
So these ships have catapults that actually accelerate the plane very rapidly.
What I want to know is if you have a plane with a takeoff velocity of 250 km/hr
on an aircraft carrier whose length is 80 m, what is the minimum acceleration you need?
And keep in mind that's in m/s² and here we have km/hr.
What's the minimum acceleration you'll need to prevent your plane from falling into the ocean?
Keep in mind that this takeoff velocity is given in km/hr, but the answer should be in m/s².